une vaccination à la chaîne qui place le
chili dans les premiers rangs mondiaux
le pays d'amérique latine a déjà injecté
au moins une dose de vaccin à 5,72
millions de personnes soit environ 30 %
de sa population et cette campagne de
vaccination ne cesse de s'accélérer ce
mercredi les autorités recensaient trois
doses administrées pour 100 habitants
premier ratio au monde devant notamment
israël
les émirats arabes unis et le royaume
uni aujourd'hui pour la première fois et
c'est une chose a souligné le chili est
le premier pays au monde pour le rythme
de la vaccination
le classement publié chaque jour montre
que le chili est le premier au monde au
dessus d'israël pas épargné par la
pandémie avec plus de 21 mille morts
depuis l'apparition du virus sur son
territoire le chili a réussi à
s'approvisionner en vaccins dès le début
de l'année 2000 21 6 21 mille doses du
vaccin fighters ont été injectés en
décembre c'est grâce à l'arrivée de 4
millions de doses du sérum du chinois
sinovac que la vaccination chilienne
s'est accéléré lundi dernier plus de 2
millions de doses supplémentaires de ce
vaccin sont arrivés à l'aéroport de
santiago
le contrat avec synovate comprend une
option pour 60 millions de doses en
trois ans sur cette option c'est à dire
sur les 20 millions de doses prévues
pour 2021 et autres pays a déjà opté
pour 14 millions de doses dont 10
millions sont déjà arrivés au chili et
pour les quatre autres millions dont
nous avons convenu dans le contrat
nous nous attendons à ce qu'elle arrive
d'ici la fin du mois en plus du contrat
avec sinovac
le chili multiplie les contacts avec
d'autres groupes pharmaceutiques pour
acquérir plus de doses de vaccins 4
millions de doses ont ainsi été
commandés auprès d'astrazeneca
mais aussi auprès de l'américain johnson
& johnson le chili a également intégré
le dispositif onusien kovacs
le chili bénéficié de deux facteurs
importants
tout d'abord je suis sûr qu'ils avaient
une bonne planification et qui l'a
judicieusement utilisé les ressources
dont il dispose pour conclure des
accords bilatéraux avec certains
producteurs de vaccins de plus le chili
participe également à kovacs ce qui
signifie qu'il a maintenu de multiples
options pour avoir accès au vaccin grâce
à la réussite de leurs campagnes de
vaccination
les autorités chiliennes peuvent se
permettre de venir en aide à leurs
voisins
le chili a récemment fait don de 20
mille doses du vaccin de sinovac au
paraguay ainsi qu'à l'équateur